so I work in marketing which I love but
my first passion was physics a passion
brought to me by a wonderful school
teacher when I had little less gray hair
so he taught me that physics is cool
because it teaches us so much about the
world around us and I'm going to spend
the next few minutes trying to convince
you that physics can teach us something
about marketing so quick show of hands
who studied some marketing university
who studied some physics at University
oh pretty good at a school okay lots of
you so hopefully this will bring back
some happy or possibly some slightly
disturbing memories so physics and
marketing we'll start with something
very simple Newton's law the force
equals mass times acceleration this is
something that perhaps Turkish Airlines
should have studied a bit more carefully
before they ran this campaign
but if we rearrange this formula quickly
we can get to acceleration equals force
over mass which means that for a larger
particle a larger mass it requires more
force to change its direction it's the
same with brands the more massive a
brand the more baggage it has the more
forces need to change its positioning
and that's one of the reasons why Arthur
Andersen chose to launch Accenture
rather than try to persuade the world
that Anderson's could stand for
something other than accountancy it
explains why Hoover found it very
difficult to persuade the world that it
was more than vacuum cleaners and why
companies like Unilever and P&G keep
brands separate like Arial and Pringles
and Dov rather than having one giant
pear and brand so the physics is that
the bigger the mass of an object the
more force is needed to change its
direction the marketing is the bigger a
brand the more difficult it is to
reposition it to think about a portfolio
of brands or maybe new brands for new
ventures now who remembers Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle getting a little
more technical now so this says that
it's impossible by definition to measure
exactly the state either position and
the momentum of a particle because the
acts of measuring it by definition
changes it so to explain that if you've
got an elementary particle and you shine
a light on it then the photon of light
has momentum which knocks the particle
so you don't know where it was before
you looked at it by measuring it the act
of measurement changes it the act of
observation changes it it's the same in
marketing so with the act of observing
consumers changes their behavior think
about the group of mums who are talking
about their wonderful children in a
focus group and almost none of them buy
lots of junk food and yet McDonald's
sells hundreds of millions of burgers
every year
think about the people who are on
accompany shops in supermarkets who
stuff their trolleys full of fresh fruit
green vegetables and fruit
but don't shop like that any other day
and if you think about the number of
people who claim in surveys to regularly
look for Paul on the web it's very few
yet at Google we know it's the number
one search for category so luckily the
science that sorry the marketing is
getting easier luckily with now better
point-of-sale tracking more digital
media consumption you can measure more
what consumers actually do rather than
what they say they do so the physics is
you can never accurately and exactly
measure a particle because the
observation changes it the marketing is
the message for marketing is that try to
measure what consumers actually do
rather than what they say they'll do or
anticipate they'll do so next the
scientific method an axiom of physics of
all science says you cannot prove a
hypothesis through observation you can
only disprove it what this means is you
can gather more and more data around a
hypothesis or a positioning and it will
strengthen it but it will not
conclusively prove it and only one
contrary data point can blow your theory
out of the water so we take an example
telling me had dozens of data point to
support his theory that the planets
would rotate around the earth it only
took one robust observation from
Copernicus to blow that idea out of the
water and there are parallels for
marketing you can invest for a long time
in a brand but a single contrary
observation that positioning will
destroy consumers belief TPP they spent
millions of pounds over many years
building up its credentials as an
environmentally friendly brand but then
one little accident
think about Toyota it was for a long
time revered as the most reliable of
cars and then they had the big recall
incident and Tiger Woods for a long time
the perfect brand ambassador well you
know the story
so so the physics is that you cannot
prove a hypothesis but it's easy to
disprove it any hypothesis shaky and the
marketing is that no matter how much
you've invested in your brand one bad
week can undermine decades of good work
so be really careful to try and avoid
the screw-ups that can undermine your
brand and lastly to the slightly obscure
world of entropy the second law of
thermodynamics
this says that entropy which is a
measure of this disorder of a system
will always increase the same is true of
marketing if we go back twenty years
that one message pretty much controlled
by one marketing manager could pretty
much define the brand but where we are
today things have changed you can get a
strong brand image or a message and put
it out there like the Conservative Party
did earlier this year with their
election poster but then you lose
control of it with the kind of digital
comment creation and distribution tools
that are available now to every consumer
it's impossible to control where it goes
your brand starts being dispersed
it gets more chaotic
it's out of your control actually saw
him speak he did a good job but while
this may be unsettling for marketers
it's actually a good thing this
distribution of brand energy gets your
brand closer to the people more in with
the people it makes this distribution of
energy is a democratizing force which is
ultimately good for your brand so the
lesson from physics is that entropy will
always increase it's a fundamental law
the message for marketing is that your
brand is more dispersed you can't fight
it so embrace it and find a way to work
with it
so to close my teacher mr. Vata taught
me that physics is cool and hopefully
I've convinced you that physics can
teach all of us even in the world of
marketing something special Thank You
investment in broadband high-speed
Internet can help small businesses
create new American jobs small
businesses are being formed dreams are
being launched and at AT&T we're
investing billions to upgrade and build
out our wired and wireless networks now
is not the time to stall momentum or
stifle innovation or investment jobs
dreams and the future are at stake ATT
your world delivered